Peace and blessings be upon the Messenger of Allah, his family, his companions, and
those who follow his guidance.
Now then, the
chapter on deeds done seeking the pleasure of Allah.
Yes, in the name of Allah, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. All praise is due to Allah, and peace and
blessings be upon the
Messenger of Allah, his family, and all his companions. Now
then,
continue moving on to the chapter
concerning those deeds done seeking the pleasure of Allah, the Exalted.
Imam Bukhari, may Allah have mercy on him, said:
Mu'adh ibn Asad told us, he said: Abdullah told us, he said:
Ma'mar told us, on the authority of Az-Zuhri, that he said:
Mahmud ibn Ar-Rabi' told me, and
Mahmud claimed that he knew the Messenger of Allah, peace and blessings be upon him. He said: He knew the water
from a bucket that was in their house. And he, may
Allah have mercy on him, said:
I heard 'Utban ibn Malik Al-Ansari,
then one of the Banu Salim, say: The Messenger of
Allah, peace and blessings be upon him, came to me in the morning and
said: No servant will come on the Day of
Resurrection saying, "There is no god but Allah," seeking thereby the pleasure of
Allah, except that Allah will forbid the Fire for him. We want
Mahmud ibn Ar-Rabi', may Allah bless him and grant him peace,
ibn Malik Al-Ansari, Banu Salim. May Allah bless him and grant him peace. There is
no god but Allah, the Exalted, the Almighty.
This is the chapter.
It contains a statement
that a person should have
sincere intentions
and always be mindful that he desires, through his actions, to seek the pleasure of God
Almighty.
Sheikh Habibullah, may God be pleased with him, Sheikh Khalid, hadith
with him, aff of sincerity, seeking the pleasure of
God Almighty. There is
no doubt that sincerity is one of the
conditions for the acceptance of deeds, as is well known.
Here, the hadith is narrated by Mahmud ibn al-Rabi’, a
companion,
on the authority of ‘Utban ibn Malik. It is a single hadith narrated by
Mahmud ibn al-Rabi’
ibn Malik, a companion, on the authority of
Sahih.
This contains a statement, and it is an
important matter, which
Ibn al-Qayyim, may God have mercy on him, pointed out. He
said, “The wise among the intelligent consider
their habits as acts of worship, while
the foolish consider their acts of worship as habits.” This is a statement by
Ibn al-Qayyim, may God have mercy on him.
[Music]
The explanation of this is
that the habits of a person, whether
believer or sinner,
may be transformed into acts of
worship that please God Almighty.
People, that is
sleep, and everyone sleeps. Some sleep to gain strength for obedience and to gain strength for the
Fajr prayer. This sleep is an act of worship.
[Music]
As Mu’adh said, “I consider my sleep as an act of worship, just as I consider my standing in prayer.” Mu’adh,
may God be pleased with him, said, “And
likewise, spending on one’s family,
buying them food, and a habit.”
But if the servant intends reward for it, it is charity,
reward, and worship.
Spending members even know that this is
an act. For example, if someone visits a sick person, like my sheikh, and one person visits him intending reward, then this is worship, unlike Paradise. Another person visits him simply because he visited him, or so that people will say that he visited him. This is worship with reward, so it is worship. This fool turned worship into a habit with his intention, so he did not take any reward for it.
He mentioned the hadith of Atban ibn Malik, in which there is the virtue of "La ilaha illa
Allah" and its obligation. The hadith of Atban ibn Malik, "
La ilaha illa Allah," and the hadith of Atban ibn Malik contains evidence of the conditions of "La ilaha illa Allah," and
that it does not benefit the servant by saying it
only. There must be conditions. Whoever knows the conditions of "La
ilaha illa Allah,"
mention them. Seven: "
La ilaha illa Allah."
Yes, the best
knowledge is knowledge, achievement, and acceptance. Knowledge, achievement, and
acceptance.
I know that you know
from the Houris:
love, sincerity, truthfulness, and sincerity.
Well done. This is what the one who
memorizes the verses says.
The sheikh is a
wise memorizer. The best knowledge is certainty, acceptance, and
meeting. What I say is
falsehood, deceit, and truthfulness. May God
grant you success. May God grant you success.  So, if this is evidence of what,
what condition?
Okay,
ma'am. Okay,
so we can proceed on time, we can change the method.
Then he cited the hadith of Abu Hurairah on the authority of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him.
The hadith of Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, on the authority of God, peace and
blessings be upon him, who said: God Almighty says: There is no reward for a believing servant with Me if I take away his beloved one from among the people of this world, and he patiently endures it, and he enters Paradise. So, his
saying here, "I do not want a reward," the reward is the recompense, and the beloved one
here is the close friend. This includes a
child, a brother, or anyone whom a person loves, whether a
sheikh or a student. So,
God Almighty
said, "except he patiently endures it," or "he patiently endures it, then he patiently endures it." And
the meaning of patience here is that he patiently endures
his loss, hoping for the
reward of God Almighty, and
then he patiently endures it. And
there came hadiths indicating that
whoever loses three children, or two children, or
one, and is patient and patiently endures it, will enter Paradise. Among the
rewards mentioned for this is that whoever is afflicted with this is a
reason for entering Paradise. And
this was mentioned in the hadith of Anas, the
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, who said: There is no Muslim who
dies  He has three blessings: He never reaches the age of puberty, may
God bless him and grant him peace, except that God, by His grace and mercy, admits him to Paradise. The
second blessing is that he is shielded from Hellfire.